hi my name is zoë baker
and this is how i within 1 year
maybe the biggest u d
c creator of the Netherlands Ben
i think everyone my s o
s passed by on their timeline
and this is what I have done Anders
I think proactively with my customers
and that actually means I have my honest opinion
which I think is best for the ads
and because of this I have several customers
who have been running my ads for 7 months
i don't focus on selling 1 video
but on multiple videos and extra options
this not only benefits the company
but I myself too
I myself only work with permanent clients
who pay me thousands of euros a month
making sure I earn every month
focusing on my personal brand
I have more than 11,000 followers last year
and it comes
because I have focused a lot on building my
personal brand
all my brands come in through built-in
and I don't know how many months
no longer out to reach you
and the latest customer relationships
I focus very much on 1 good band
my customers so they keep coming back
and this is so valuable to me
follow for part two